[Musik]
wie macht man sich ein bild von menschen
die ein land führen wollen von denen es
schon so viele bilder gibt lässt sich
hinter die fassade schon
[Musik]
das muss noch schöner werden
wir haben sie fünf monate lang
beobachtet
[Musik]
im auf und ab im wahnsinn der sich
wahlkampf nicht
deutschland steht vor einem wechsel die
macht wird neu verteilt
[Musik]
ein sonntagnachmittag im
regierungsviertel es gibt etwas zu sehen
einen knallharten machtkampf
da kommen zwei die dasselbe wollen
kanzlerkandidat der union werden sie
haben es nicht geschafft dass hinter den
kulissen abzuräumen
ich bin bereit zu dieser kandidatur und
wenn die cdu dies in breiter mehrheit
unterstützt dann glaube ich ist es okay
armin laschet ist der drei monaten
cdu-chef er glaubt seine partei hinter
sich
[Musik]
ich finde die parteigremien müssen jetzt
morgen die chance haben das in aller
ruhe zu beraten es ist für beide wichtig
für armin und mich für uns beide dass
wir die entscheidung nicht auf biegen
und brechen fällen es kommt zum biegen
und fast zu brechen
söder zwingt laschet zum duell in die
gemeinsame bundestagsfraktion aus cdu
und csu
verschlossene lamelle was geheim
ausgetragen werden sollte wird zur
live-übertragung jedes wort wird ein
teilnehmer nach draußen
für laschet sieht es schlecht aus er
argumentiert mit inhalten so damit
seinen viel besseren umfragewerten viele
abgeordnete auch der cdu haben angst mit
laschet ihren arbeitsplatz zu verlieren
eine schweigt angela merkel sie hat
angekündigt zu ihrer nachfolge kein wort
die sitzung endet ohne ergebnis
söder glaubt die zeit spiele fühlen die
entscheidung dürfe nicht im hinterzimmer
fallen sagt er
die grünen träumen ihre k-frage
geräuschlose ab
so guten tag und guten morgen zu einem
in der tat besonderen tag in diesem
wahlkampf wird uns die erste grüne
kanzlerkandidat hinführen annalena
baerbock lieber anna-lena bitte die
bühne gehört die
coaches harbeck verschwindet in der
kulisse vorerst bei den grünen hat die
frau den vortritt
schönen guten tag auch von meiner seite
bin zutiefst davon überzeugt dass dieses
land einen neuanfang braucht um gut
durch dieses neue herausfordernde jahr
zehn zu kommen mit diesem auf sicht
fahren
das haben wir aber schon immer so
gemacht und wenn es dann doch sein muss
dann drehen wir halt noch so ein
stellschräubchen weiter da kommen wir
nicht weiter
[Musik]
annalena baerbock hatte die berliner
bühne schnell erobert
2013 kommt sie in den bundestag vier
jahre später in den jamaika sondierungen
für sie fielen auf auch in union und fdp
durch akribie detailversessenheit
durchhaltevermögen
auch robert habeck lernt sie damals
kennen
wir wählen hier heute nicht nur die frau
an robert seite sondern die neue
bundesvorsitzende von bündnis 90 die
grünen ein
[Musik]
2018 werden beide parteivorsitzende und
geben sich dabei ein versprechen
dann saßen wir beide dann auf der bühne
von dem parteitag also im grunde ein
total öffentlicher moment 1000 leute und
wahrscheinlich hat schillings noch
übertragen und alle gucken zu und hat
sein vertrauter moment weil wir auf
einmal bieten sondern auch des orkans
auf einmal zuerst mal nebeneinander
saßen als gewählte bundesvorsitzende und
da haben wir dann gesagt so jetzt lasst
uns das gemeinsam machen sonst dass es
nicht den fehler machen wir davor da war
dass wir uns gegenseitig ausspielen
wer bock und fahrwerk schneiden die
partei auf sich zu anders als früher
treten die grünen plötzlich geschlossen
auf das neue ding noch die partei
regierungsfähige
streitigkeiten gibt es aber mit weniger
ideologie und selten öffentlich
würden sie sagen dass sie freunde sind
freundschaft ist für mich persönlich ein
hohes wort aber wir sind politisch
befreundet und wir sind auch seit drei
jahren so viel im austausch dass wir auf
unserer ebene des duos miteinander
befreundet sind das ist unsere stärke
dass wir auch verschieden sind aber dass
wir im respekt und im freundschaftlichen
miteinander leben verantwortung
übernehmen
[Musik]
erste kanzlerkandidaten der grünen ein
bittersüßer moment ruft robert habeck
ihr noch hinterher
per zeitungsinterview
ja
am abend desselben tages
armin laschet schalter die
cdu-parteispitze zusammen bundesvorstand
auch markus söder ist eingeladen nimmt
aber nicht teil er hatte das gremium als
hinterzimmer bezeichnet von wegen aus
der turbulenten sitzung wird wieder
alles öffentlich
im moment ist diese sitzung in einem
ziemlichen kipp punkt angekommen noch
führt söder mit großem abstand vor armin
laschet für laschet haben sich
beispielsweise wie günther und glauben
an ausgesprochen für söder haseloff
wegner röcken und bedingt auch glück und
dann soll es irgendwann in der nacht
möglicherweise erst nach mitternacht zu
einer möglicherweise geheimen abstimmung
kommen
ein drittel des eigenen vorstands
versagt laschet schließlich die
gefolgschaft
[Musik]
es ist wie so oft in seinem leben erst
angezählt verlässt den hof gerade so als
gewinner aber nicht aus eigener kraft
die alte cdu garde um wolfgang schäuble
hat ihn durchgeboxt
[Musik]
markus söder hat sicherlich an einem
punkt
die entscheidung für armin laschet stark
befördert nämlich an dem punkt wo er die
legitimation des bundesvorstandes der
cdu infrage gestellt hat und das kann
eine cdu nicht akzeptieren und das hat
sicherlich mit dazu beigetragen dass
auch diejenigen die eigentlich eine
andere meinung hatten
dann für armin laschet eingetreten waren
als kanzlerkandidat der union
machtkampf die härte von einem laster
unterschätzt
nein alle die in der politik der
verantwortung übernehmen wollen sind
bereit auch diese verantwortung zu
machen und es war ja im endeffekt waren
ja andere sehr stark da engagiert
armin hat sich da menschlich sehr fairen
korrekt verhalten deswegen bleibt da
nichts war andere haben schon ein
bisschen übertrieben aber das ist in
solchen zeiten ganz normal
[Musik]
laschet ist kandidat einer union die
tiefe risse hat
er versucht gleich am ersten tag alle zu
umarmen
bis zur selbstverleugnung
[Musik]
wir sind in der cdu
ist dankbar für den guten
fairen umgang in einer sehr
weitreichenden entscheidung auch in
einer sehr persönlichen entscheidung
reicht das aus
wenig deutet darauf hin aus münchen
treten die verlierer nach lassen laschet
alt aussehen als mann der vergangenheit
sie werden monatelang so weitermachen
ich bedanke mich sehr bei
arbeitsgemeinschaft gerade bei den
jungen bei den modernen bei denen die
auf zukunft auswahl für ihre wirklich
überragende unterstützung und lasse mich
ganz persönlich sagen markus söder war
erkennbar der kandidat der herzen
das getöse bei union und grünen hat
einen fast vergessen lassen den dritten
bewerber
bei der spd hat olaf scholz die
kanzlerkandidatur schon seit monaten in
der tasche
und nicht nur die
das heißt ja es würde sich in dieser
tasche immer ihr parteibuch verbergen
stimmt das das stimmt
weil ich früher ja oft bei parteitagen
und gremiensitzungen mein parteibuch
vorzeigen musste dann habe ich zwei
reingesteckt da bist buy belassen und im
übrigen habe ich sie mittlerweile in so
einem schutzumschlag gepackt weil es war
von 1975 ist und allmählich ein bisschen
auseinander fällt wie man wahrnehmen
kann aber es ist original sie haben
gesagt sie mussten vorher mal vor zeigen
wann hört er das auf wenn ich jetzt zum
parteitag geht wissen die meisten dass
ich stolz bin und auch spd mitglied
[Musik]
ist scholz wirklich spd pur
die frage begleitet ihn von anfang an
mitte der siebziger gehört er zum links
dogmatischen flügel der jusos legt sich
mit spd bundeskanzler helmut schmidt an
wettert gegen dessen rüstungspolitik
heute stellt er sich gern mit schmidt in
einer reihe
[Musik]
ein paar jahre als rechtsanwalt
außerhalb der politik sind für scholz
lektionen im kreis mathis muss
[Musik]
anfang der 2000er wird der
generalsekretär von bundeskanzler
schröder
unbeirrbar verteidigt scholz damals die
umstrittene agenda politik
später wird er zweimal minister unter
angela merkel versteht sich mit ihr
ausgezeichnet
[Musik]
doch die regierungs lust hat einen preis
als scholz 2009/10 spd chef werden will
bestraft ihn die partei scholz
unterliegt einem duo aus bis dahin
weitgehend unbekannten er der
langgediente pflichtmensch
[Applaus]
haben sie den folgenden tagen war
irgendwann gedacht aufzuhören der
politik dazu müsst ihr diese partei
es ist irgendwie eine merkwürdige
haltung wenn man selber etwas was man
unbedingt was man gerne machen wollte
nicht machen kann daraus gleiche den
schluss zu ziehen dass man alles
hinwirft das
habe ich mal irgendwo als waschlappen
haltung bezeichnet und empfinde sagt
der größte widersacher von choice ist
2009 10 ein junger mann mit linken
idealen kevin kühnert
das neue spitzenduo gilt als sein werk
er steht hier im hintergrund
ich halte es auch weiterhin für richtig
dass er nicht parteivorsitzender
geworden ist und zwar nicht weil er olaf
scholz ist sondern und das war unser
hauptargument auch damals weil er teil
der bundesregierung war wenn so jemand
jetzt die parteispitze übernimmt
resigniert ein großer teil der
mitglieder und sagt es wird einfach
nichts mehr die spd kommt aus diesem
staatstragenden wir machen hier die
regierungsarbeit und die partei hat das
zu schlucken wir kommen da nicht mehr
raus lange ringt die spd ob sie einen
kanzlerkandidaten benennen soll
in umfragen liegt sie hinter den grünen
schließlich tut sie es trotzdem
wir wissen auch dass diese entscheidung
für viele in der partei vielleicht auch
außerhalb der bahn hat eine
ungewöhnliche bindung darstellt ich
freue mich über die nominierung
und ich will gewinnen
annalena baerbock zu besuch bei startup
unternehmen die akribische ist unterwegs
und wie viel ist jetzt auf dem court
kein fand das heißt es gibt immer wieder
zurück der kunde zahlt nur wenn das
nicht zurückschickt das hat ihr sammeln
plastik weltweit oder was in welcher was
für plastikflaschen hinter die komplette
stocker und da wäre auch mein vorschlag
ein system zu schaffen dass man sagt
schulrat zu werden zurückgenommen um sie
zu reinigen um sie dann zu spenden für
soziale einrichtungen
baerbock will ein image besetzen dass
ihr keiner der konkurrenten liegen kann
sie ist es vierzig und mutter kleiner
kinder
macht der schwangerschaft und
[Gelächter]
dritte kinder
hätten sie jetzt
schlagzeilen werden kommen aber andere
als beliebt sind
ein wahlkampf abend in sachsen-anhalt
olaf scholz erscheint durch die
hintertür
wartet wie oft was auf ihn zukommt
er ist kein menschen magnet seine partei
in diesen tagen auch nicht weh nicht
eingemauert bei 14
es ist auch keiner der die welt umwälzen
will seine botschaft keine zumutung
keiner soll sich fürchten vor zu viel
veränderung trotz klimawandel und trotz
weltweiter konkurrenz
ihr müsst keine sorge haben wo der
zukunft ja die welt wächst zusammen aber
wir müssen uns deswegen nicht sorgen
weil wir können mit dem was wir jetzt
machen dafür sorge tragen dass wir auch
hierzulande technologisch vorne mit
dabei sind und das wäre heute gute
arbeit hat für sich und seinesgleichen
und seine kinder sagen kann auch in zehn
und 20 jahren wird das hierzulande noch
der fall sein dafür werden wir
jedenfalls kämpfen
noch eine kleine sache ich wünsche mir
olaf scholz als kanzler für 20 21 da
wollte ich nur mal
also
danke
scholz hat einen unsichtbaren gegner
das verlierer image der spd
ich bin überzeugt dass jeder der weiß
dass eine langstrecke an der langstrecke
ist auch weiß dass die schlussphase die
anstrengendste ist aber wir haben die
puste dafür
videodreh für den grünen wahlkampf
slogan in sichtweite des kanzleramtes
mit farbe auf curcuma basis biologisch
abbaubar
die partei sieht sich gut im rennen auf
augenhöhe mit der cdu
alles scheint möglich
das freut auch den wahlkampf leider
[Musik]
ich glaube schönes bild von oben bei
einer hebebühne
mit den bildern klar im wahlkampf geht
es auch um bilder
allerdings das image der
kanzlerkandidatin hat erste risse sie
musste bonuszahlungen ihrer partei als
nebeneinkünfte nachmelden hat ihren
lebenslauf aufpoliert
handwerkliche fehler
auch der wahlkampf leitung
[Musik]
ich glaube dass fehler im wahlkampf
natürlich auch passieren dass wird immer
wieder passieren das wird ja nicht so
sein als wird alles immer immer glatt
laufen die konsequenzen noch genauer
hinschaut und noch genauer sich abstimmt
und stelle reagiert denn wenn das hoch
läuft diese ganzen auch weiterhin
vorkommen in den nächsten wochen monaten
ja ich schließe überhaupt nichts aus
dass wir nicht noch weitere fehler
machen wir sollten nur neue und andere
fehler sein
[Musik]
armin laschet unterwegs als
kanzlerkandidat er besuchte
ministerpräsidenten von sachsen anhalt
reiner haseloff
dessen landes-cdu waffe markus söder
fotos gern gemeinsame auftritte vor
bürgern lieber nicht eine landtagswahl
steht bevor der kanzlerkandidat wird er
versteckt für sich selbst formuliert
laschet einen bemerkenswert kleinen
anspruch das kleinere übel sein das
genügt
das stelle ich überall fest aus sachsen
anhalt nur mehrere einladungen die ich
gar nicht alle schafe in einzelne mal
kreise also da sagen jetzt alle wir
wollen lieber dass du kannst nur was als
frau baerbock und das völlig eine
berechtigte frage stellung
besuch in einem kloster
tradition und glaube sind laschet
wichtig er glaubt auch dass in der cdu
vorsitz zum ziel trägt
bei angela merkel hat es ja vier mal
geklappt eine fehleinschätzung
zwei wochen nach seinem besuch gewinnt
die cdu die landtagswahl in sachsen
anhalt der sieg geht mit haseloff nach
hause nicht mit laschet
als laschet die bundespolitik betritt
geht er als moderner in der cdu ist
redenschreiber für die kohl
widersacherin süßmuth und bricht doch
nicht mit dem kanzler lager
bis heute wohnt laschet in seiner
geburtsstadt aachen er braucht das
heimatgefühl
2005 wird er in nrw deutschlands erster
integrationsminister
[Musik]
seine politische karriere steht mehrmals
kurz vorm aus nach nur einer wahlperiode
fliegt er aus dem bundestag verliert
später im kampf um den cdu landesvorsitz
in nrw gegen norbert röttgen und gewinn
2017 die landtagswahl äußerst
seitdem regiert er in nrw mit nur einer
stimme im jahr
laschet steht in vielen fragen an
merkels seite auf 2015 ihre
flüchtlingspolitik
während der pandemie setzt er sich ab
von ihrem kurs ist früher öffnen zeigt
ein völlig anderes
wissenschaftsverständnis als die
kanzlerin
immer wenn jemand ankommt und sagt die
wissenschaft sagt ist man klug beraten
zu hinterfragen was dieser gerade im
schilde führt denn die wissenschaft hat
immer auch winter meinung und wenn es
ein einzelnes
aus dem kampf um ihre nachfolge hält
sich merkel monatelang demonstrativ raus
[Musik]
bei der spd läuft die kampagne zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch geplant aber großen
auftrag
fotoshooting für die scholz plakate die
partei setzt nur aus
[Musik]
schön schön ist genau wie
schokolade
wie sitzt man einen scheiß ins ziel
wie war das mit dem tisch
[Musik]
ein bisschen wasser theorie etwas
positiveren
es wäre es uns zu einfach ganz toll auf
das muss noch schöner werden
dass es wieder schöner wird hoffen auch
die grünen ein parteitag soll sie ins
reich der inhalte führen die fehler der
kandidaten vergessen lassen
ein letztes mal wirkt der baerbock habe
kur
wir wissen natürlich dass
kameradschaft und solidarität sich nicht
beweist wenn die sonne scheint und der
wind von hinten kommt sondern genau dann
wenn der wind von vorne kommt oder
jemand im regen steht deswegen für die
zukunft
deswegen für die zukunft mit
gelassenheit und stärke durch dick und
dünn
hatte das gefühl da die partnerin
schützen stützen zu müssen
es hat nichts mit hilflosigkeit der
partnerin zu tun aber dass man wenn
jemand gerade in schweren gefahren
natürlich
läuft nicht sich wegduckt das gehört
schon zu meinem inneren herrn könig
eure volle solidarität zu spüren roberts
ich da an meiner seite zu wissen
das hat kraft gegeben und volle power
und dafür herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
trotzdem die anspannung bleibt hoch das
zeigt ein kleiner vorfall
baerbock hat sich in ihrer rede
verhaspelt am ende bleibt dem mikrofon
eingeschaltet eine sekunde zu lang
[Applaus]
st
am ende des parteitags ist klar die
stimmung hellt hd kuch nicht baerbock er
will feiern sie die kontrolle behalten
die vergangenen wochen haben sie noch
misstrauischer gemacht
wie beschreiben sie den arbeits stil von
annalena baerbock
man kritisch
fordernd und
meinungsstark
wenige tage später steht wer wird ihr
punkte die debatte über ihre fehler
glaubt sie überwunden
dass
jedes punkt und jeder punkt und komma
angeschaut und umgedreht wird das war
mit unser kanzlerkandidatur ankündigung
für uns
genau das passiert auch erklären die
plagiatsjäger finden abgeschriebene
stellen angeblich mehr als 100 auf 240
seiten
der ruf der akribischen baerbock ist
dahin es kostet sie viel glaubwürdigkeit
und die grünen zustimmung
schon wieder ein fototermin für urlaub
schuld mit kandidierenden für die spd
wollen auffällig viele junge menschen
ins parlament ein drittel ist unter 40
sehr zur freude von kevin kühnert scholz
früheren widersacher viele von denen die
hier sitzen sind kühn als freunde können
sich auch eine koalition mit grünen und
linken vorstellen
scholz hat für diese option wenig
sympathie
aber er schließt sie auch nicht aus
und und wild und hinter ihm sitzt olaf
scholz
an kevin kühnert zeigt sich exemplarisch
eine veränderung der spd plötzliche
geschlossenheit als es um den vorsitz
ging zur kühner die strippen gegen
scholz mittlerweile zeigt er sich gern
mit ihm sagt nur gutes selbst über
scholz hang zur besserwisserei
[Musik]
zur vollendung kommt politik dann wenn
man dann noch den letzten schritt
schafft nämlich das ganze zu übersetzen
in
parlamentarisches handeln
regierungshandeln verwaltungshandeln
auch der perfektionismus mit dem er
versucht das zu machen und dass auch
andere spüren lässt dass er es besser
kann als man selbst das kann
das ist ja die diesen ärger den ich als
juso häufig gespürt habe wenn er mich
das hat merken lassen der ist
gleichzeitig antrieb zu sagen
dass
das bin ich irgendwann will das gerne
auch andere spüren lassen
dass der frieden in der spd hält auch
nach der wahl dafür gibt es keine
garantie eine niederlage wäre das
politische aus für olaf scholz
kühn hat dagegen weiß auch dann seine
truppe hinter sich
die union stellt ihr regierungsprogramm
vor wir unterschreiben jetzt den vertrag
der erste gemeinsame auftritt seit dem
kampf um die kanzlerkandidatur
nichts ist geheilt selbst über das was
sie schwarz auf weiß ins programm
geschrieben haben werden sie noch
streiten
das ist ohne groll und es ist auch eine
es ist eine ähnlich gute zusammenarbeit
die wahl bin schon vorher da und diese
zehn tage haben es nicht kaputt gemacht
weiß ob das auch bestätigen kann sich
sehr gut
[Musik]
söder les clöchards auflaufen wann immer
er kann er finde ich fast den ganzen
wahlkampf lang
es ist ganz wichtig dass wir in den
nächsten wochen dokumentieren das ist
nicht nur darum geht sich mit schlaf
fragen ins kanzleramt zu fahren auf
langsame geschwindigkeit wir müssen
jetzt zu legen das ist die zeit endlich
zu kämpfen ich habe keine lust keinen
bock auf opposition habe ich bin der
antreiber ist das auch ein verarbeiten
der niederlage gegen assad ihrerseits es
gibt niemanden der eine flasche zu lobt
wie ich
und deswegen glaube ich ist diese lob
ist auch gerechtfertigt und richtig und
ich glaube und hoffe auch sehr das ist
wirkungszeit markus söder bezeichnet
sich als antreiber ist das für sich auch
die korrektur rollen beschreibung nein
die cdu treibt
viele ideen wir haben das wahlprogramm
sehr geprägt und diese
unterschiedlichkeit zwischen cdu und csu
die gab es immer schon auch jetzt gibt
es unterschiedliche akzente wir sind
unterschiedliche typen aber ich glaube
programmatisch sind wir so eng zusammen
wie lange nicht mehr
auch der selbsternannte antreiber wird
abstürzen in den umfragen es fällt nur
weniger auf als beim kanzlerkandidaten
laschet
[Musik]
ein vierteljahr vor der wahl verlässt
olaf scholz das land drei tage
washington
es gehe um eine globale mindeststeuer
erklärt er den mitreisenden journalisten
mit an bord ist dann engster vertrauter
wolfgang schmidt seit 20 jahren an
seiner seite als büroleiter referent
jetzt staatssekretär und berater
ich mache jetzt hier eine
sache die ich als bundesminister der
finanzen auf den weg gebracht habe für
die deutsche regierung also auch als
vizekanzler und natürlich spielt bei
vielen entsprechen eine rolle dass alle
mit denen ich rede wissen dass sich auch
der nächste regierungschef werden kann
das kann man gar nicht voneinander
trennen
regierungschef scholz viele beobachter
haben ihn längst abgeschrieben
[Musik]
aber dafür gibt es ja wolfgang schmidt
stundenlang kann er predige scholz werde
aufhören sobald die wähler aus dem
urlaub kommen es werde ein duell scholz
die eigene partei traum ist ein recht
mehrfach dokumentiert und lebenslust und
fisher price als erkenntnissen glaubt
klar
höhepunkt der reise besuch bei us
finanzministerium scholz braucht ihre
zustimmung zu der mindeststeuer und er
braucht bilder die sagen ich kann
weltpolitik
[Musik]
machen kann ist nicht ein
globale mindestbesteuerung für
unternehmen wie amazon und facebook nur
wenige deutsche haben bisher davon
gehört
scholz erklärte in washington zu seinem
meisterstück in leadership
führungskraft
die sache ist jetzt auf dem gleis das
wird nicht mehr aufzuhalten sein es ist
wahrscheinlich im bereich faire
besteuerung in der welt der größte
durchbruch seit den letzten 10 20 jahren
später stellt sich heraus so sicher ist
das alles längst nicht trotzdem stolz
ist gelöst wie selten
wolfgang schmidt verrät die strategie
merke kopieren um merkel zu folgen
ich glaube dass das was die bürgerinnen
und bürger angela merkel schätzen
eigenschaften sind jemand auch bei olaf
scholz findet also der ist ganz klug
kennt sich aus ist verlässlich und das
ist glaube ich etwas was die bürgerinnen
bürger bei olaf scholz auch erlebt haben
sowohl zweimal als bundesminister und
dann natürlich auch in seiner zeit als
hamburger bürgermeister wo ich glaube
wenn man objektiv drauf kommt man schon
sagen kann das hat er ganz ordentlich
gemacht wirklich
in scholz zeit als bürgermeister für die
affäre um die warburg-bank
stichwort comics scholz wird vorgeworfen
zu gunsten der privatbank das finanzamt
beeinflusst zu haben der schaden für die
steuerzahler geht in die millionen vor
einem untersuchungsausschuss behauptet
scholz sich an den inhalt der gespräche
nicht zu erinnern
gehört das nicht auch so leadership
solche dinge sehr klar und präzise zu
haben
eins ist ganz klar es hat keinen
einfluss auf die steuerverwaltung
gegeben ich bin sehr froh darüber dass
es mittlerweile einen ausschuss gibt in
denen die verantwortlichen
vertreter der finanzverwaltung das von
sich aus auch bestätigt haben
damit ist das klar
keine eigenen feder sieht scholz auch im
mojácar skandal eine behörde seines
finanzministeriums geht lange nicht vor
gegen den milliardendeal ganz betrug in
dem unternehmen
auch hier muss scholz für einen
ausschuss dass sein haus versagt habe
oder gar er selbst weist er zurück
[Musik]
scholz dunkelste stunde bisher der
g-20-gipfel 2017 in hamburg der damalige
bürgermeister verspricht das treffen der
welt politiker werde wie ein
hafengeburtstag
die polizei hat sich sehr gut
vorbereitet das sind tolle leute die
souveränen und sehr gelassen vorgehen
werden und sicherstellen werden dass es
alles so weit wie möglich friedlich
bleibt es bleibt nicht
randale plünderungen die polizei
überfordert
scholz kann die bürger nicht ausreichend
beschützen er muss es eingestehen auch
wenn ihm so etwas äußerst schwer fällt
[Musik]
dafür
dass das geschehen ist bitte ich die
hamburgerinnen und hamburger um
entschuldigung
[Musik]
sylt amrum für
robert habeck ist auf küsten tour allein
tagelang hat er nach der box
buchveröffentlichung geschwiegen jetzt
nicht mehr
das ist die summe von lauter kleinen
fehlern jeder für sich war nicht
wichtig in der summe hat es natürlich
dem
image geschadet
aber es ist ein image und die person an
der lena berger bis anders kann mehr und
wir haben noch zwei monate das führt zu
sorgen zu kämpfen die chancen zu nutzen
dass genau das wieder erkennbar wird
[Musik]
auch habig hat ein image je mehr viele
annalena baerbock macht desto größer
erscheint ihr
[Musik]
geplanten wechsel an das wäre blödsinn
halte ich nichts da muss er jetzt durch
das war erfolgreich
wenn wir nicht aufpassen verlieren wir
als erstes die wir vom ziel kanzleramt
spricht habe ich nicht mehr und baerbock
erwähnt er nur auf nachfrage
es bleibt der eindruck hängen die
rückendeckung für annalena baerbock als
kandidatin ist aktuell wichtiger als
alles dafür zu tun die chancen aufs
kanzleramt wieder zu erhöhen
das wirklich die richtige priorität
kandidatur berbalk ist wichtiger als die
grünen im kanzleramt
das was ich damit verbindet nämlich
loyalität zudem zu dem projekt das man
gestartet hat
muss sich daran messen lassen ob sich
die loyalität auch in schwierigen phasen
durchhält
haben sie jemals überlegt die kandidatur
an robert habeck nochmal abzutreten
der wahlkampf ist für uns holprig
verlaufen auch gerade zu beginn gab es
rückschläge aus aigen verschuldeten
rückschläge wo man natürlich selber
reflektiert wollen das nicht kalt lässt
und sagt mensch das hätte man aber
besser und das hätte man anders machen
müssen und ich bin kein typ der dann
sagt jetzt stecke ich den kopf in den
sand weil es mal hart wird über zwei
richtigen gegenwind gibt weil ich es
nicht richtig gut gemacht habe sondern
wir nehmen ganze kraft für die
erneuerung in diesem land weil so viel
in unserem land drinsteckt
ende des vorzeige duos der machtkampf
den die grünen bisher vermieden haben
droht ihnen nach der wahl
mitte juli eine katastrophe mehr als 180
menschen sterben im hochwasser in
rheinland pfalz und nordrhein westfalen
ausgerechnet in der heimat von armin
laschet die flut zwingt den wahlkampf in
eine neue richtung
laschet ist schnell vor ort besichtigt
die schäden gibt den kümmerer
deutschland beginnt über den klimawandel
zu diskutieren die die alles verloren
haben quellen andere sorgen
politik interessiert uns momentan in
keinster weise was uns interessiert ist
dass wir wieder ein dach über dem kopf
haben was die spinner sagen mit ihrer
klimapolitik das ist was ich sage aber
uns im moment später kann man darüber
noch lesen
als landesvater muss sich ums aufräumen
kümmern als kanzlerkandidat müsste er
sich dem großen ganzen stellt erhitzung
doch er bleibt immer modisch
weil jetzt ein solcher tag ist ändert
man nicht die politik das ziel co2
reduzieren muss ein langfristiges sein
und dann liefert laschet ein fatales
bild ein lachen an unpassender stelle
ausführlich wird darüber berichtet
laschet bitte noch am selben tag um
entschuldigung aber das bild hat sich
längst eingebrannt dabei zeigt er sich
bei seinen besuchen hier meist zuhören
mitfühlen
[Musik]
diese bilder kommen nicht angehen dass
eine öffentlich kleben bleibt das lachen
nervt sie das dass sie auf dieses bild
reduziert werden ja das ärgert mich
selbst am meisten weil ich habe mich für
nichts wirklich in der letzten zeit so
engagiert wie für die hochwasseropfer
ich bin hingegangen wenn schwierige
situation war wenn menschen aufgewühlt
sind weil die dinge nicht so schnell
gehen und wenn dann immer nur nach
diesem bild gefragt wird dann das und
wie bekommt man das als politiker wieder
weg gar nicht durch gute arbeit
[Musik]
ein anderer macht sich laut feder zu
nutze olaf scholz setzt ein grimmiges
gesicht auf ich kann es besser soll das
heißen
gemeinsam versprechen sie finanzielle
hilfen scholz ist der finanzminister
vorbereitet
der bund finanziert die andere hälfte
und das geld kann gewissermaßen
abgerufen werden es geht also so schnell
wie es gehen kann der wiederaufbau kann
beginnen
[Musik]
bisher haben die umfragewerte der union
geschwächelt ab diesem punkt stürzen sie
ab
die grüne kandidatin war auch im
flutgebiet aber bewusst ohne fotografen
die katastrophe lenkt die aufmerksamkeit
auch so aufs grüne uhr thema klimaschutz
der burg & harbeck zeigen sich erstmals
wieder gemeinsam und locken die
hauptstadtpresse ins moore um ein
sofortprogramm vorzustellen neue idee
ein klima ministerium das ministerium
hat dann entsprechend auch ein vetorecht
gegenüber anderen ressorts wenn eben
gesetze nichts auf dem weg zum 15 grad
fahrt und das heißt paris kompatibel
sind
klima im fokus laschet im sinkflug an
dass die grüne kanzlerschaft noch retten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein politisches grundanliegen von armin
laschet lässt sich an diesem ort
ausleuchten olpe im sauerland
die junge union hat eingeladen zum
wahlkampfauftakt
laschet sieht die gesellschaft
auseinander driften radikale ränder
stärker werden auf beiden seiten etwa in
der korona politik
ich nehme das ernst ich nehme es ernst
dass menschen sorgen haben in einer
solch weltweiten pandemie aber was
unsere aufgabe als cdu ist es die
gesellschaft zusammenzuhalten
nicht diesem populistischen ton bei
einem so ernsten thema nachzubilden
es folgt ein live praxistest eine impf
gegnerin hat sich zutritt verschafft zur
cdu veranstaltung
[Applaus]
gleich was
not
haben sie abgegeben danke der cdu kann
man das der meinungsfreiheit und freuen
uns lassen
so jetzt noch mal so eine synthie
wohin das umarmungsstrategie führen kann
zeigt sich in der ersten reihe friedrich
merz sein ehemaliger konkurrent um den
parteivorsitz jetzt möglicher minister
in einem kabinett laschet
auf der anderen seite sitzt es herab
bühler
integrationsstaatssekretär laschet gilt
als ihr förderer bühler und märz passen
nicht zusammen
der knackpunkt
hans-georg maßen die südthüringer cdu
hat den ehemaligen verfassungsschutzchef
als bundestagskandidaten aufgestellt
einen mann der auch afd positionen
vertritt von einer weltverschwörung
around
rechtsextremismus relativiert hat bühler
reagiert entsetzt auf diese kandidatur
sie twittert
ihr habt echt den knall nicht gehört wie
kann man so irre sein
märz hat mit maßen dagegen kein problem
ich halte das für inakzeptabel ausbau
grüner da gesagt hat nochmal das ist
eine beamtete staatssekretär in der
landesregierung die sich anmaßt
öffentlich die leute für ihre zu
erklären ich respektiere diese
entscheidung dieses wahlkreises das habe
ich doch von hier aus nicht zu
kommentieren
es geht um eine existenzielle frage
wieviel fd position duldet die cdu im
eigenen haus der parteichef müsste eine
linie ziehen wenigstens intern doch
laschet lässt es einfach laufen versucht
den konflikt jovial weg zu schätzen
[Gelächter]
in dieser konkreten situation haben sie
gelacht über das wort beschimpfung und
letztendlich das bis zur unkenntlichkeit
sozusagen dann stehen lassen weil sie
kommen sonst klar die haben eine
unterschiedliche meinung gehabt und das
darf man doch einer partei mal haben in
einem wesentlichen punkt darf man
unterschiedlicher meinung sagen ja
[Musik]
annalena baerbock ist unterwegs in ihrer
alten heimat pattensen bei hannover sie
besucht eine neue bio hühnerfarmen
auch hier geht es um bilder aber auch um
die botschaft veränderungen im sinne der
grünen sind längst im gang
veränderung betont baerbock auch in
ihren reden hallo zu sagen
schön gute nachmittag freue mich
wirklich riesig hier zu sein schon
verboten zumutungen verzicht spricht sie
nicht auch für die grüne gilt möglichst
niemanden verschrecken es könnte
wählerstimmen kosten
es steckt soviel großartiges in unserem
land wenn die deutsche industrie sagt
wir können das klimaneutralität dann
muss auch die zukünftige bundesregierung
den mut haben diese erneuerung
deutschlands voran zurück
warum wagen sie nicht den viel größeren
bruch mit der politik angela merkels zum
beispiel beim thema klima mir die
umsetzung beim klimaschutz die mangelt
ja nicht an den menschen im land die
mangelt auch nicht mehr an den
unternehmen in unserem land das muss
halt politik machen politik muss die
gesetze dafür machen dass wir aus dem
fossilen verbrennungsmotor aussteigen
und den kohleausstieg deutlich deutlich
vorziehen
einen vorgezogenen kohleausstieg dort
mittlerweile selbst die konkurrenz an
und corona hat viele menschen
veränderung niedergemacht
ich wünsche ihnen kraft und hoffnung und
dicker auf
820.000 ist richtig wir sind
150.000
ein guter monat vor der wahl das
kampagnen team der spd ist bestens
gelaunt der trend geht tatsächlich in
die höhe die von scholz umfeld
vorhergesagt in einigen umfragen zieht
die spd sogar an der union vorbei
erstmals seit fast 20 jahren ein
motivationsschub
das ist auch an den fehlern der anderen
liegt egal
kann es auch über zwei jahren ich weiß
praxis an kann zwar für klimaschutz
und kanzler für sichere arbeit ich weiß
dass an also auch da konsequent die
kopfnicker themen fortsetzen sie sind
geschlossenheit von personen
programmpartei dass das haben nur wir
aber jetzt sind 41 tage und da muss man
jeden tag aufpassen dass nichts schief
läuft jeden tag
in diesen 41 tagen passiert tatsächlich
noch etwas eine staatsanwaltschaft wird
razzia anordnen im ministerium von olaf
scholz
die hintergründe sind undurchsichtig
einmal mehr heißt der vorwurf
aufsichtsversagen
haustür wahlkampf in berlin armin
laschet ist erstaunt
als parteizentrale will gute bilder
verbreiten hat sagt medien eingeladen
und dafür gesorgt dass dort wo der
kandidat klingelt auch tatsächlich
jemand zu hause ist
ja man hat mich gefragt weil der
verfassungsschutz muss mich ja vorher
überhaupt guten kann er nicht jeweils
sie herkommen und vielleicht billigen
al-kaida-anhänger und bin ihm zu nahe
ganz nach plan läuft die aktion trotzdem
nicht weil armin laschet armin laschet
ist auf alle vorbereitung pfeift und
klingelt wo es ihm gefällt das läuft
nicht immer rund für ihn ist ihm
allerdings egal
politiker die nur noch geglättet durch
die gegend rennen nur noch gefeierte
sätze sagen und nicht mehr empathie für
den der einem gerade etwas sagen will
schenken will so etwas ermutigen will
wenn sie das einfach alles abblitzen
lassen dann ist das unauthentisch und
das will ich nicht sagen
wann ist olaf scholz mal richtig
unvernünftig
gibt es überhaupt
ich versuche in dem was sich politisch
mache
mich an den kriterien der vernunft zu
orientieren
und ich glaube das ist ganz gut so
ein letztes mal unterwegs mit annalena
baerbock im wahlkampf bus das kamerateam
darf ein paar kilometer mit fahren
auch nach einem halben jahr beobachtung
es die keinen blick zu in ihre seele
letzte wochen oder monate waren hart
aber auch persönlich viel einstecken
müssen wir haben sie den wahlkampf für
sich persönlich verpackt
verkraftet
es geht jetzt in die richtig heiße phase
des wahlkampfs und wo es vorher viel
persönliches ging zeigt jetzt eigentlich
deutlich dass diese wahlen richtungswahl
ist und deswegen kämpfen wir als grüne
kämpfen robert habeck und ich und ich
persönlich als kanzlerkandidatin jetzt
diese letzten drei wochen mit allem was
wir haben dafür dass wir uns gemeinsam
als gesellschaft diese nur zutrauen
wirklich eine veränderung und eine
erneuerung unseres landes jetzt
anzugehen
sie will uns jetzt so langsam zum ende
kommen super danke
zweieinhalb wochen vor der wahl armin
laschet ist unterwegs nach paris zu
einem treffen mit präsident makro
offizielle als kultur bevollmächtigter
der bundesrepublik
die umfragewerte werden nicht besser
die partei ist hochnervös fragt jetzt
fast täglich wann liefert laschet
endlich den wendepunkt
der werdende punkt ist der wahltag am
wahltag entscheiden die wählerinnen und
wähler und dann werden
grund entscheidungen der politik
entschieden dann wird nicht über vieles
nebensächliche diskutiert was wir in den
letzten wochen erlebt hat
daheim hat sich inzwischen die
bundeskanzlerin eingeschaltet sich
eindeutig für laschet als ihren
nachfolger ausgesprochen dabei wollte
sie sich doch raushalten
die person geführt auf dem dach der
deutschen botschaft gespräch mit
journalisten
laschet zeigt sich nachdenklich
in diesem moment wie zwei wochen vor der
wahl wie sicher sind sie sich dass die
bundeskanzlerin kann sich nicht sicher
sein weil es eine knappe wahl wird wir
spüren dass alle dass es jetzt um eine
richtungsentscheidung geht und deshalb
tue ich alles was ich kann dass wir
diese wahl gewinnen aber sicher darf man
sich bei wahlen nie sein sie könnten
zweiter werden
sein dass wir gewinnen es könnte auch
sein dass man nicht gewinnt
schliesslich spd großkundgebung in worms
mittlerweile heißt das duell scholz oder
laschet doch scholz hat mindestens zwei
probleme dass eine nach wie vor das
image seiner partei
lasst uns allen ein geheimnis verraten
wer will dass der nächste kanzler olaf
scholz heißt der muss damit es klappt
spd wählen schönen dank
[Musik]
auf die razzia im ministerium verfolgten
walter wieder so eine komplizierte sache
die nicht jeder sofort versteht das ist
vielleicht sein glück
ist mir noch völlig unklar ob er
überhaupt irgendwas davon wissen konnte
muss man ja mal gucken und die sachen
der vergangenheit ich denke wenn man
denn der politik ist gibt es bei jeder
irgendwas was nicht gelaufen ist wie
sollte das könnte natürlich umschwung
geben es kommt jetzt darauf an wie die
konkurrenz das nutzt
[Musik]
ein letztes mal nachgefragt eineinhalb
wochen vor der wahl
verlieren es keine perspektive
ich will erfolgreich sein weil dieser
wahl für die spd und auch für mich und
ich habe den eindruck es könnte klappen
ist die bürgern und bürger mehr in
auftrag geben und wenn nicht ich bin
sehr zuversichtlich
fünf monate sich beweisen fünf monate
auf und ab für annalena baerbock armin
laschet und olaf scholz
der wahlkampf war ein härtetest die
eigentliche bewährungsprobe kommt erst
noch
[Musik]